[Musica]
presentate molto bene grazie mille sono
molto emozionato non è il mio mestiere
di fare queste cose
il cross e per me è un po in causa del
mio mestiere
il cross di essere chef adesso non siamo
più neanche chef adesso siamo maestri
siamo di divini vediamo senso una roba
incredibile della somma di volte la
gente ti chiede si tuffa in grado da
mangiare
fai un mestiere ti chiedo non si tuffa
il tuo mestiere e questo mi fa mi fa
sorridere e ora fortuna di essere
arrivati in italia da voi e tanti tanti
anni fa ho fatto la mia la mia carriera
ma non chiesto di parlare del caos
non voglio parlare del mio mestiere
perché il mio mestiere molto bello
caotico televisione redazione del sole
chef e scrivano dei libri fanno di film
sulle shafran cartoni animati su e chef
non parliamo delle scienze io vorrei
parlare del mio caos cosa cosa intende
così successo perché il caos
il mio primo caos che ho avuto è che ho
vissuto e quando li so non si fa più ma
quando si chiede di andare a fare il
militare
e parlo di un po di anni fa
34 35 anni fa
devi fare un nano l'anno di militare e
questa voglia di fare il militare non
hai intenta voli e non hai voglia di
farsi tagliare i capelli non ha voglia
di camminare voglia di sparare a a
niente a nulla
e tu sangue che questo quell'anno lì che
tu devi fare sarà utile forse può essere
utile forse lo capisci dopo io non
volevo fare e allora avevo trovato
questa specie di soluzione di a quell
epoca li ha
dotto cucina che ha inventato ha creato
con altri medici mai creato messa in sol
frontiera aveva aveva la possibilità di
fare il servizio militare con il dottor
cucina il problema era di firmare per
due anni a fare una cosa un anno che non
ti serve a niente imparare qualcosa io
ho firmato due anni e siamo partiti in
gibuti e che era la base la cona
dell'africa e abbiamo fatto la somalia e
yemen e devo dire che questi tutto
questo tempo con l'aereo
quando sono arrivata a gibuti ho capito
forse a 19 anni cosa voleva dire forse
la prima volta io non lo sapeva ma il
caos quelli addosso nel source e teo di
aereo dove tu hai tutto vivi l'attuale
tuo modo di vivere le tue vent'anni e in
sete o di aereo
tutto finito la gente non mangia non
beve una miseria all'incidente e tu devi
andare a vaccinare tutte queste queste
popolazione e vedere come fanno loro a
vivere e non lamentarsi da un caos così
così folle da vent'anni tu non vuoi in
questa cosa non vorrei vedere però tu
pensi che facendo questo
tra parentesi aiuto umanitari sta
risolvendo quelle cose sono passato al
più di 34 anni il cross è sempre uguale
perché credo che non abbiamo tanta
voglia di fare qualcosa per questa gente
poi dopo to rientri dopo due anni dove
non ti sei accorto così successo al
giorno un tuo cervello ti accorgi quando
oriente india goji che tu non puoi più
entrava un supermercato perché ti metti
a piangere tu non riesci più a rientrare
dove sono nato io in montagna si non c'è
un ventilatore chegia perché non riesci
più a dormire vedono stesso questo caos
della vita di tutti i giorni quando ci
sei e non succede niente
ma quando ti riprendi la tua vita tra
parentesi normale qui succede del grande
una grande confusione e un grande caos
no che vai vedere delle persone che ti
aiutano e la magia del cervello che è
fantastica sparisce queste cose o forse
non sparisce va da una cassettina da
qualche parte è unito è bello per
aprirla per pensa a un pochino poi dopo
la vita riparte
faccio la mia la mia vita e la mia
carriera e poi dopo l'incontro con
l'italia incontro con l'italia
all'inizio tu arrivi e anche qui un
altro carossa
ma il caos perché sono rimaste il caos
della gentilezza della simpatia della io
viaggiavo tanto e ho cominciato
mi sono fermato ho incontrato un
contratto voglio stesso da una ventina
sono andata avanti per la mia carriera
che tuttora sta andando molto bene
all'interno del mio lavoro un giorno
suona il telefono è la persona che mi si
presenta mi dice che è padre spirituale
e o a quell epoca li avevo un amico che
mi faceva tanti scherza il telefono e io
l'unico voto riconosciuto in so chi sei
questo signore o meno esponenti uguali
che si lei guarda ai vedenti cativa del
del vaticano è vero vedo una negativa io
non sono indicativi del vaticano ma vedo
che non è il numero dove abito io posso
segnare per questo padre mi stava
dicendo che la santa sede aveva scelto
me per fa da noi già al papa
e questo per 60 giorni è stato un caos
caos di rex della fregata ma un caos e
di control la mia famiglia il mio
personale il mio fornitore per farà
mangerà una persona tanto tanto rispetta
il nostro papà ma è incredibile come
devi fermarti per poter fare solo da
mangiare una persona che è un dato che è
andato tutto bene vedendo il senso c'è
un sacco di gente che forse voleva
incontrare il papa
a me il papa venuto da me non ho chiesto
niente ci siamo anche parlato è stato
molto bello è una persona veramente
molto molto gentile perché deve essere
gentile e questo stato diciamo un caos
impotente perché non stai facendo a
mangiare a io ho fatto da mangerà tutti
e farò continuano a far da mangiare a
tutti anche alle mense dei poveri a
milano a brescia avevano senso con la
mia equipe non cerchiamo di dentale
banca o se di fare le cose che sappiamo
fare attraverso il nostro mestiere e poi
dopo è stato il carrozze del 9 nel 9 di
marzo
il caos è del 9 di marzo stato
allucinante io mi ricordo che la sera il
sabato sera cominciavano a suonare i
telefoni in ogni ristorante la lombardia
chiude gente che ha fuori del dalla
lombardia mi chiedeva di fare il conto
erano ai primi e secondi di gente che
avevamo annunciato metà the sea
andiamo via andiamo via un caos totale
in a dalla mia sale io non riuscivo a
capire
sapevo giustamente della cona virus ma
non riuscivo a capire questa paura non
entrare sembrava un momento di così di
guerra
roba incredibile e poi dopo è successo
nella cose che è successo
la chiusura un altro caos totale
cosa fa il tuo ristorante 25 dipendente
persone che contano su di te gente che
forse ha cominciato acquistare una casa
versanti aspettano
un bambino contano su di te e dunque
certi di trovare le soluzioni e le
soluzioni le abbiamo trovato e poi un
giorno un altro colpo di telefono
professor tomasoni professor tomasoni è
la professione del reparto cona via
russe di brescia che mi dici è un giorno
figli visto che è un cliente mio sì
conosciamo non siamo amici ma si
conosciamo e mi dice fini ma potresti
venire a far da mangiare al mio
personale e sono rimasto molto colpito e
devo dire che impaurito di questa costa
che rim ha detto levy fa da mangiare ha
giustamente no al mese dell'ospedale di
brescia solo al reparto da una cosa che
abbiamo sistemate come cucina dove solo
i miei ragazzi che i miei dottore
possono andare e ti viene in queste
specie di paura di amare perché io devo
andare a cucinare non so se io lo prendo
questo con avis che non è impossibile
perché diciamo il sistema di prevenzione
sanitaria è impossibile e io l'ho fatto
una cosa che voglio dire che quelle foto
che abbiamo visto per queste ragazze
questi dottor questi infiammi era tutti
segnati maturi e vedi in televisione ci
si può in iran contro livelli veramente
davvero è una botta molto forte
veramente e non riesci a capire non
riesci a capire perché un professore
chiede a un chef a un cuoco di mini a
far da mangiare
io l'ho capito dopo perché loro avevano
bisogno di un non di mangiare bene ma di
mangiare diversamente avevano bisogno di
una coccola perché loro vivevano banca o
se 12 ore
14 16 o al giorno a quel momento lì il
pranzo lì non era il fatto di mangiare
bene malefatte di sedersi e di guarda
una cosa fatta bene ma cosa credo
abbiamo cercato di fare il più bello
possibile perché è un sentito mi son
sentito di fare veramente di più che a
un cliente che mi paga perché loro hanno
un dato veramente tanto a noi e io credo
che questa cosa e noi tutti
sarà questa cosa sarà scritto che lo sul
sun è vivo e di storia dei nostri figli
i nostri nipotini di fini no perché sono
grandi e grandissimi mia firma
forse i miei nipotini dove sarà scritto
così successo il 2020
cosa abbiamo vissuto e cos'è così
successo e io credo che ci sarà da da
ricordarsi la stava è molto attento
perché credo che stato da the dead e
grande lezione di comportamente come
determinate alla fine come noi tutti ci
siamo comportati chi si comporta bene
chi si comporta male
in italia vedere che non esiste più il
lievito da un supermercato è stato il
caos hanno parlato in televisione
dunque credo che sarà da da ricordare
questa cosa io me lo ricorderò tutta la
mia vita perché non che ho fatto una
cosa bene ma avevo fatto una cosa che
forse volevo fame è stata una persona
che mi ha spinto fa quella roba lì e
sono stato molto orgogliosa sono state
le grandi momenti ci siamo commossi e
anche a parlare dei sommi di premi un po
perché sono tanti belli queste righe di
questi anni gode con questi ragazzi con
questi dottori con tutto il personale
non solo chi è medico o infermiere alle
altre persone che tantissimi persone
adesso sono entrate non diciamo
una sfera delle persone che amo e niente
questo è la mia idea del caos che il
caos e si può tranquillamente affrontare
basta essere non dico intelligente basta
avere la testa basta essere ma va a
persone si può affrontare
tranquillamente questo volevo dire basta
[Applauso]